last question today is from avi avi says
what are you currently reading and what
are you currently watching okay uh I'll
go first with what I currently watching
as far as movies I've not seen like a
non I guess I'd call it a fiction a non
documentary I haven't watched a non
documentary for a very very long time I
just watched a really interesting
documentary called sour grapes about a
wine counterfeit er which I'm sure I'm
gonna recommend to you at some point i
recently watched a documentary about
which have already recommended ivory in
what's going on with ivory so much a lot
of documentaries as far as TV shows
here's where i am uh I am finishing up
the blacklist season 3 it's not my
favorite show but I'm so in it now and I
do like a lot of the characters that I'm
gonna finish it up then I'm gonna go to
season 3 of black mirror which I still
is it's on my cue I'm waiting to get to
then I'm gonna go to season two of the
man in the high castle which is an
Amazon original and then after that I
think it will be time by then probably
for season 3 of better call Saul yes and
at this point it might be season four or
five I think maybe five of the Americans
those are the shows right now I want to
see better call Saul but I don't even
think the second season is up on netflix
yet so i'm waiting around for that right
i think only season one is on netflix so
far in as far as documentaries go
there's is fantastic when I think you
would like to as a as a talk show host
it's called I know that voice and it
goes into the lives of voice actors yet
okay you have seen it yet people who uh
cover voices for cartoons and you really
get to see a sneak peek in in the people
behind the voices that is a good
documentary yeah and not only do you see
some of the cartoon voices but you see I
believe some of the famous like movie
trailer voices that are really common I
believe that that's part of that
documentary yeah weather like in a world
where this in the south yeah exactly
that is good and then as far as what am
I reading I'm currently finishing up
william gibson is one of my favorite
sci-fi writers and i'm finishing up his
latest book the name escapes me uh the /
i think it's called the peripheral i
have to admit it's not my favorite
gibson stuff neuromancer by gibson was
awesome but this latest book I'm not
really liking and I'm looking forward to
getting through it uh I recently
finished the bastards of Pete's
Falcone which is translated from the
Italian by mauricio DiGiovanni a great
Italian crime fiction writer recently
finished that I'm also reading in
Spanish 100 years of solitude by the
great late uh uh Marcus uh Gabriel
Garcia Marquez and I've never read that
before and I know that it's a it's a
true classic at first I was worried if I
read in Spanish somewhat regularly but
there's a lot of sort of fantastical of
vocabulary and I was worried about
whether my Spanish which which uh
speaking obviously I'm completely
comfortable at a native speaker in but
my reading of spanish literature is less
comfortable but about 40 pages in and
it's great so far i don't know if you've
read that in english i assume in English
it would have to be yet I mean that's
pretty fascinating as a lot of people
may feel completely comfortable speaking
a language but when it comes to reading
especially writing it yeah they they
kind of struggle with them yep no doubt
but it's going going great so far the
book is amazing and I'm working my way
through that and also for nonfiction I
recently finished uh Robert Allen's book
mastery that was really good and I
recently started Daniel Dennett's book
uh intuition pumps and other tools for
thinking or something like that
intuition pumps is definitely part of
the the subject and uh that's really
good so far about 30 or 40 pages and on
that I would love to go through the
classics that I read in high school and
read them again because I was not
particularly interested in them at the
time and didn't pay too much focus on on
you know getting some value out of them
but rather just to pass a test or a read
an essay on them yeah and you know these
books get referenced all the time it
would be great to read them again
Beowulf I read in like sophomore year
and I hated it and I bet that if I were
to read it now I would just get so much
more out of it in my head I sort of have
some negative associations with it
because I didn't like the teacher that I
had at the time and I didn't like the
way it was being taught and I didn't
really care about English class in
school and so it's negatively associated
in my brain but I'm sure if I would read
it now I would think it was much better
that's the thing now you can just read
it and enjoy it for what it is instead
of having to uh appease the teacher I
plan I'm gonna try to get a lot of
reading done on our
upcoming end of the year break all right
we've got a great bonus show for you
today no time to tell you what's on it
what I do have time to mention very
quickly though is that you can use
coupon code I voted 17 to get a
40-percent discounted membership at
david pakman.com slash membership and
david pakman.com slash donate is where
you can donate to our crowdfunding
campaign